what's up everyone james murphy here from
mcoding.io where i offer live online courses
in python today we're going to be talking about
how to find primes using the sieve of eratosthenes
so before we can write the sieve of eratosthenes
first we have to understand what the algorithm is
here's the main idea you start with a big array
let's say we want all the numbers that are prime
less than 100 then we'd make an array of length
100 full of booleans the booleans are going to
tell us whether the number is prime or
not initially everything is set to true
and then we're going to go through and
successfully mark composite numbers false
so first we start at 2 that's prime then we take
all of the multiples of 2 bigger than 2 of course
and mark them as false because they're composite
then look through our array and the next thing
that's still marked true has to be prime that's 3.
do the same thing for 3 mark all of the multiples
of 3 that are bigger than 3 as false then look at
the array again and you'll see that 5 is the next
smallest thing so let me show you a little graphic
from wikipedia that shows the algorithm in action
okay so as you can see right now it's going
through marking out all the multiples of two
then it finds three as the next prime number it
marks out all of those and then it finds five
and then it marks out all the multiples of five
and then it finds seven then marks out all the
multiples of seven and so on and so forth so the
idea is go to each number that's marked true and
mark out all of its multiples as false then as you
go through the things that are still marked true
as you go in order up from two you'll find that
all of those things that are still marked true
are primes okay so now we understand the general
idea of how the algorithm works let's get into how
to actually implement it in python so i've already
written here just the definition of the function
we're going to be calling it primes less than it
takes an integer where i want all of the primes
that are strictly less than that integer and i
wanted to return a list of integers the primes
so first off let's get rid of some trivial
cases if n is less than or equal to two then
well there are no primes less than two
so let's just return the empty list
otherwise let's make an array which
tells us whether a number is prime
so we're going to have booleans in the
array that are all initially set to true
and i want the length of the array to
be n so 1 for each number in our range
then of course i will initially set 0 and 1 to be
false so is prime of 0 is false and is prime of 1
is also false because 0 and 1 are not primes next
we go through and start marking out composite
numbers so we'll go for i in range of 2 to n now
actually we don't need to go all the way up to n
because if you have a composite number
then it has at least two factors
and one of those two factors at least one of
them needs to be less than the square root of n
so we don't need to check all the way up to n we
only need to check up to the square root of n so
let me actually change this i'll go ahead and use
the built-in i square root function so from math
import i square root to get the smallest or sorry
the largest integer less than the square root of n
so this will allow us to not have to
go all the way up to n but only up to square root
of n so that's going to be much more efficient
so i'll go through all the numbers from 2 up
to the integer square root of my number and
then i'll check to see if i have a prime so if is
prime of i and if so then i need to mark out all
of the multiples of that number that are bigger
than that number so i'll say for x in range now
another optimization that i can do here
is i can actually start at the square
of i and the reason for this is
again if i had a factor that was
less than i then it should have already
been marked out by the the previous
iteration of the loop so in fact
all i need to do is start out with
the multiples of i that are bigger than or
equal to i squared so we'll start at i squared
and go to n is the biggest and if i started
i squared which is multiple of i and i jump
by i each time then that's going to give me all
those multiples so just to remember the order of
the arguments here the first one in range is the
starting value the second is the stopping value
not including that value and then the
third is the amount to jump by at each step
so i'll go through these and then
mark everything in here as not prime
then that's basically it i just need to now
return the ones that are still marked prime
at the end of it so i'll just say return
i for i in range of n if is prime of i
and if i didn't make any typos that should
be it so there you have it 2 3 5 7 11 13
17 19 and so on that looks good to me
so there you have it that's how you can
find all the primes less than a certain
number using the sieve of eratosthenes